[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 une édition pour
revenir sur l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi 22
février
c'est officiel la ligne 18 est bien
confirmée premier tronçon retardé de
2024 à 2027 sur le plateau de saclay le
métro rejoindre à versailles comme prévu
en 2030 dans ce journal les réactions à
ces annonces du premier ministre
retour également sur plusieurs mois de
rebondissements il s'ouvre ce samedi à
paris porte de versailles le salon
international de l'agriculture se tient
jusqu'au 4 mars
ile de france aura son stand pour
promouvoir les exploitants du de la
région un espace animé par là à le
servir le centre régional de
valorisation et d'innovation agricole et
alimentaire
enfin dans ce journal on vous parlera
également de ce stage à voisins le
bretonneux des enfants qui ont pu
confectionner une oeuvre recyclé invités
de ce journal claire et be des vernets
qui a animé cet atelier l'ensemble des
lignes du grand paris express sera mené
en intégralité à mai avec des reports de
calendrier annonce ce matin du premier
ministre edouard philippe et de la
ministre des transports elisabeth bornes
pour réaliser ce chantier du siècle
gouvernement souhaite aller au plus vite
mais en maîtrisant l écoute des coûts
déjà très pharaonique de 10 à 35
milliards d'euros selon la cour des
comptes
je vous le disais en titre le premier
tronçon de la ligne 18 entre l'aéroport
d'orly et le plateau de saclay donc
retardé de 2024 à au plus tard 2027 le
prolongement à versailles via saint
quentin en yvelines et lui a bien
maintenu à 2030 et les travaux vont
bientôt démarrer je vous propose
d'écouter à ce propos la ministre des
transports elisabeth bornes
concrètement cela veut dire que dès
cette année des travaux préparatoires
vont commencer notamment à massy opéra
puis dans les prochaines semaines au
niveau du christ de saclay des
démolitions auront également lieu à
anthony dès le mois de mars le marché
pour les ouvrages annexes au niveau
d'orly sera notifiée et les travaux
préparatoires sur orly démarreront dans
la foulée dès cette année le budget de
la société du grand paris pour la
réalisation de cette ligne sera de 35
millions d'euros
et d'ici la fin du quinquennat 690
millions d'euros auront été engagés pour
cette ligne
autre annonce de la ministre d'état
ministre des transports en attendant la
ligne 18 un renfort de l'offre desserte
de bus entre massy et saint quentin en
yvelines sera opérée est mise en place
de nouvelles circulations en site propre
et les études sont lancées dès cette
année pour un début des travaux fixé à
et forcément face aux annonces à la
confirmation de la ligne 18 plusieurs
élus du territoire se sont exprimés le
député de la république en marche didier
baichère salue le chantier du siècle
pour la france et se réjouit que l'état
est enfin pris assez à décision sur le
dossier et didier baichère qui fait
partie des 21 élus à avoir interpellé
premier ministre sur la ligne 18 cette
semaine lé député yvelinois de la
république en marche qui avaient été
conviés aujourd'hui par le premier
ministre edouard philippe à ce sujet
avant les annonces officielles étaient
présents notamment est nadia et béatrice
piron comme vous pouvez le voir sur ce
twitt et de la députée aurore bergé elle
réaction plus critiques à présent celle
de la de la région ile de france à
propos du premier tronçon entre orly et
saclay est la région qui n'est pas
satisfait du un nouveau calendrier de la
collectivité nouveau calendrier du grand
paris express selon la collectivité ce
retard au déploiement du grand paris
express ce nuirait aux clusters
paris-saclay la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse va convoquer les
présidents des départements pour
explorer des pistes d'accélération de
réalisation des lignes enfin le
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
erwan le gall se veut lui plus ironique
ils demandent le report des jo-2000 24 à
2032 pour que l'événement puisse voir à
la ligne 18 saint quentin en yvelines
demande est une arrivée de la ligne sur
le territoire et ce dès 2024
autre réaction à présent celle-ci
téléphonique cette élue elle n'est pas
opposée à l'arrivée de la ligne mais est
opposé au tronçon en aérien qui doit
voir le jour sur le plateau de saclay
bertrand guillon le maire de magny les
hameaux n'est pas surpris sur ces
annonces du premier ministre
en revanche il juge nécessaire la mise
en place de nouvelles circulations en
site propre sur saint quentin en
yvelines comme annoncé par edouard
philippe
l édile demande également l'organisation
d'assises de la mobilité pour régler
d'autres questions épineuses en matière
de transport les études ont déjà existé
la déclaration d'utilité publique existe
depuis des années et encore il ya eu des
études récemment sur le haut niveau
archéologique
donc tout ça avant c'est la seule
problématique c'est le financement
aujourd'hui clairement oui l'état doit
prendre la main doit trouver le
financement sur sur cet axe là qui déjà
règlerait un certain nombre de
problématiques d'accès vers notre
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il faut absolument que chaque
institution dans ses compétences mettre
enfin la main à la pâte dans cette
régate yves sur eux tout ce qui a été
discuté qui est dans tous les plans
schémas différents hauts depuis depuis
des années mais qui n'a jamais abouti
la prolongation du rer c d'un côté ce
transport en commun en site propre pour
ollier 51 matchs
la rénovation du rer b mais en fin de
journal nous recevrons le président et
maire de saint quentin en yvelines jean
michel fourgous pour une nouvelle
réaction
cette ligne 18 si elle vient d'être
confirmé dans son ensemble a fait parler
en tout cas beaucoup d'elle pendant de
nombreuses années et est même un temps
évoquée la possibilité d'avoir à saint
quentin en yvelines deux gars le passage
également en souterrain était envisagé
du côté de voisins
bretonneux retour dans le passé dans nos
archives avec nicolas kirillovitch l'on
passe pour l'instant on fait du jour le
grand paris express le verdict est tombé
en 2013 déjà la rédaction de tv 60,18
faisait sa une sur le grand paris
express
à l'époque ne dit pas ligne 18 mai ligne
verte
effectivement on parle de ligne 18 à
présent la femme une ligne verte le
projet rebaptisé nouveau grand paris et
si en 2013 la ligne verte ou plutôt la
ligne 18 comporte encore de gare à saint
quentin en yvelines
ce n'est plus tout à fait le cas fin
2014 à l'époque se pose aussi la
question du passage en souterrain ce qui
départ acté aujourd'hui c'est savoir
surfer de leiria et du souterrain est
sûre fait donc deux gars ou une gare le
problème c'est que l'enveloppé
financière est elle si j'ai finalement
le schéma avec une gare sera validée
mais c'est alors le tracé qui pose
problème à voisins le bretonneux on
s'inquiète du passage de la future ligne
sous un quartier de la ville
il ya beaucoup de maisons où il ya des
micropieux à 15 20 m de profondeur et
donc forcément les gens sont inquiets et
c'est logique sur le devenir de leur
maison si on creuse en dessous suite à
l'enquêté publique réalisée en 2016 la
société du grand paris re tiendra
finalement le passage près du golf
national à guyancourt
il validera aussi le passage en viaduc à
magny les hameaux une option que la
ville a toujours rejeté on va se
retrouver avec une technologie qui est
fait du tout nouvel qui est pas du tout
durable qui est pas du tout innovantes
c'est tout simplement la technologie des
années 80-90 du fameux projet météores
est dernier épisode en date pour la
ligne 18 il y a quelques mois les élus
de saint quentin en yvelines se
mobiliser suite à des informations
parues dans la presse
nous avons des bruits qui arrive jusqu'à
nos oreilles comme quoi les
parlementaires et sonia poserait auprès
du gouvernement pour revoir ces
choses-là dont nous faisons entendre
haut et fort que nous nous voulons cette
ligne 18 confirmés dans les yvelines en
2030 le futur de la ligne 18 pourrait
être encore bouleversée
c'est l'histoire qui nous l'enseignent
pour être complet sur la ligne 18 nous y
revenons ce soir au cours du 7-8 débat
une émission entièrement consacrée à ce
nouveau calendrier annoncé ce matin par
le premier ministre edouard philippe
le reste de l'actualité vous en êtes
peut-être rendu compte depuis trois
jours la distribution de courrier et
colis est perturbé à saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs dizaines de facteurs
sont en grève pour une durée illimitée à
l'appel de la cgt
il dénonce une réorganisation de leur
travail souhaitée par la direction et
dénoncent leurs conditions d'activité
selon eux douze postes seraient menacés
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines les précisions au micro de
nicolas kirillovitch tous les deux ans
ont subi des réorganisations qui
supprime environ 10% du personnel
si on pouvait entendre que les
réorganisations et et absorbable il ya
dix ans aujourd'hui forte force est de
constater que les facteurs ils
n'arrivent déjà pu rentrer à l'heure
avant on avait le temps de faire du
social on avait le temps de faire un
bien notre travail
aujourd'hui on voit quand on connaît le
côté social qu'on demande aux personnes
âgées de payer si jamais on ils veulent
que le facteur discute avec eux et c'est
aussi dans l'actualité le s'ouvre ce
samedi le salon international de
l'agriculture se déroule jusqu'au 4 mars
c'est à paris expo porte de versailles à
paris pour en parler sur ce plateau avec
mon invité frédéric arnould un bon soir
sa dette le président des jeunes
agriculteurs d'île de france devait y
avoir également avec nous jean-claude
guennec et le président du cervia c'est
le centre régional de valorisation et
d'innovation alimentaires et agricoles
pour parler du stand ile de france
inquiète sera encore une nouvelle fois
sur ce salon de l'agriculture peut être
que monsieur guennec va arriver entre
temps c'est pas grave on va commencer
cet entretien déjà sur sur ce salon
alors avant qu'on parle de ce salon je
voulais aborder cette actualité avec
vous avez rencontré aujourd'hui le
président de la république emmanuel
macron faisiez partie d'une délégation
de 1000 jeunes agriculteurs qui
rencontrait le président de la
république s'était déjà c'est la
première fois depuis son élection que
rencontriez emmanuel macron ou et où
c'est la première fois et resserré que
on n'a pas souvent l'opportunité d'aller
au palais de l'élysée donc c'était
difficile de refuser l'invitation
et puis si on était toujours on voulait
savoir ce qu'ils avaient à nous dire est
clairement parce que on avait peur que
ce soit uniquement une action de
communication avant le salon et que
enfin on sait juste là pour une photo et
pour avoir quoi bon il ya quand même eu
un discours avec avec un fond et des
choses qui ont été dites moi je reste
quand même assez mitigé mais bon je
trouve qu'il ya des bonnes choses il ya
de la cohérence
il ya tout un tout un volet sur les 5
milliards d'euros qu'il avait annoncé
pendant son ce sont avant son élection
et du coup on sait qu'il va comment il
va et et les utiliser on sait que ça va
être beaucoup axé sur l'investissement
l'innovation sur des fonds de garantie
fin pour aider les jeunes à pouvoir
innover en tout cas sur leur
exploitation
ok avec ça c'est certain point certaines
choses
en fait on sait qu'il va y avoir un gros
accompagnement de parts de la part de la
bpi pour nous aider
bon public d'investissement exactement
précise pour nos téléspectateurs
donc pour nous aider à investir et faire
en sorte qu'on ait accessibilité
beaucoup plus facilement à des emprunts
donc ça ça apporte de la cohérence
maintenant il faut voir comment ça se
met en application
alors garanti pour les jeunes
agriculteurs des emprunts à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros c'est ce qu'il a c'est
ce qu'il a annoncé
oui c'est en gros à peu près ça après il
ya différents il ya différentes
thématiques différents systèmes non
cobras ont tant que c'est pas mis en
place on peux pas encore juger mais en
tout cas sur le principe c'est déjà ça
ça nous va plutôt bien
ensuite on a parlé mercosur vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui sur les contrats de libre
échange entre l'europe et les pays
d'amérique du sud
on avait eu en à fait différentes
actions syndicales notamment hier pour
dénoncer le fait que on importe des
produits
enfin des aliments qui sont pas cultivés
avec les mêmes normes que la france et
l'europe
vous avez pu dénoncer un double discours
à la fois d assise sur l'alimentation où
on parle de bien manger du bien manger
et ses traités qui sont signés qui
pourrait amener et boeuf et donc ils
essayent de nous rassurer
ils essayent de nous rassurer en nous
disant qu' il y aura des contrôles
sur les produits qu'on va faire rentrer
son nez au marché moi je veux bien qu'il
y ait des contrôles mais en fait c'est
pas ça qu'on demande
nous on demande qui est des droits de
douane parce que on pourra jamais être
persuadé que ce qui rentre sur nos
marchés et cultivé avec avec avec des
normes qui sont équivalentes aux notes
on sait très bien que en argentine ou au
brésil on utilise avec des ogm on
cultive avec des matières actives qui
sont des fois pas plus autorisée chez
nous donc enfin nous on subit ça
directement non clairement c'est des
droits de douane qu'on demande et puis à
un dernier sujet enfin qui pour le coup
n'a pas été évoqué et qui qui m'embête
un petit peu parce que depuis le début
de sa mandature on entend on l'entend
jamais prendre la parole sur les
filières et notamment sur la filière
céréales en fait on a l'impression que
c'est un plan de l'agriculture qui
laisse complètement de côté donc encore
aujourd'hui ça pas été abordés pas du
tout à aucun moment on parle d'élevage
de viande bovine on parle de
d'aviculture d'apiculture de maraîchage
l'arboriculture mais jamais de céréales
moi je me pose la question en fait
comment comment on peut se passer de 7
milliards d'euros sur la balance
commerciale française
comment on peut se passer de l'image de
marque de la baguette à la française qui
est à une marque de qualité pour la
gastronomie française les grandes
régions céréalières on pense à la beauce
qui est sûre les yvelines et l'essonne
aussi on hamm est exactement on a
l'impression d'être les oubliés de tout
ça les états généraux de l'alimentation
clairement ça s'adressait quasiment pas
à nous ou pas du tout voilà enfin quel
avenir quel avenir on veut donner à
cette filière quoi ça représente quand
même 50 % de la surface agricole
française donc c'est quand même pas
négligeable
donc on a compris des annonces vous
attend dès maintenant que ce soit mise
en application si on parle de ce salon
de l'agriculture là on est à deux jours
de l'ouverture là l'objectif pour un
syndicat comme les jeunes agriculteurs
sur un sur un tel salon c'est quoi ces
objectifs le premier objectif c'est que
bon on aura on aura
un emplacement sur le centre de la
région ile de france où on pourra
communiquer nos actions d'installation
on aura aussi la possibilité de montrer
au grand public le site devenir
agriculteur en ile-de-france qu'on a
inauguré au festival de la terre au mois
de septembre
donc on aura quelques actions de
communication autour de l'installation
et puis voilà plus globalement au niveau
du salon ce qu'on attend c'est assez de
montrer nos produits et de nous mettre
en valeur et et on sait qu'on a tous les
feux des médias sur nous donc c'est le
moment de faire passer des messages de
communiqué c'est un événement qui attire
chaque année beaucoup de monde 619 mille
visiteurs rien que l'an passé
pourquoi votre avis c'est un salon qui
clôt français pourquoi c'est un rendez
vous incontournable chaque année mais
parce que je pense que
toutes les fins je pense que tout le
monde a forcément un moment donné de
preuve de loin une attache avec le monde
agricole soit par ses parents ses
grands-parents et arrière-grands-parents
tout le monde à 2 de près de loin une
attache en tout cas avec le monde rural
et le fait d'avoir des vaches à paris
d'avoir des tracteurs à paris les
moissonneuses à paris c'est pas courant
et et ça attire ça attire les urbains
mais ça attire aussi beaucoup les
enfants etc pour c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est le salon le plus dit le
plus visité en france alors sur l'île de
france il ya plus de 550 mille hectares
de terres agricoles
il ya des signes région qui est autonome
en persil en salade on n'oublie pas le
blé à de la bosse bien sûr quelle
véritable grenier à blé de la france
cette agriculture france yen que vous
allez promouvoir sur ce salon est ce
qu'on la connaît assez à votre avis je
pense qu'il ya quand même des
productions con qu'on connaît mal
je pense au cresson par exemple qui pour
le coup
l'île de france est plutôt même
l'essonne et est le département où qui
nous lie à la capitale du cresson en
france dont l'airé bien la ville on
croit là exactement
voilà il ya quand même des productions
on fait aussi du foie gras en ile de
france on fait aussi du miel on fait
aussi de la menthe poivrée on fait aussi
un certain nombre de productions qui
sont en très très spécifique à
l'ile-de-france qu'on connaît mal et
c'est le moment de mettre en avant
toutes ses productions 6e c'est à dire
quand on pensait agriculture on a
tendance à mettre en avant d'abord la
province avant l'île de france c'est
c'est un constat que vous avez ou pas du
tout
je sais pas si c'est si c'est oui oui
c'est sûr que l'ile-de-france
naturellement est pas considérée comme
une région agricole mais moi je pense
que vous allez dans l'est des coups
sortent et de la petite couronne
non dans les départements de grande
couronne les gens savent qu ils ont une
agriculture de proximité et on le voit
bien tous nos maraîchers tous nos
éleveurs qui vendent en direct en
ile-de-france ont pas du tout de
problème pour écouler leur marchandise
donc c'est que on sait qu'il ya quand
même de l'agriculture en ile de france
et cette agriculture français ne
laissera découvrir ou redécouvrir sur le
salon de l'agriculture qui aura un stand
up ile-de-france sur ce salon de serre
en agriculture je rappelle les dates 24
février au dimanche 4 mars de site
internet pour avoir plus d'informations
celui du cervia également le site
officiel du salon de l'agriculture merci
à frédéric arnould d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle président des jeunes
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france et des
jouets des pieds de micros et même des
panneaux de signalisation tous re sic
tout se récupère et à voisins le
bretonneux on le prouve
grâce à la haye depuis lundi des jeunes
de la ville crée des sculptures pour les
accompagner une artiste vie chinoise
claire binet verna qui sera avec nous
dans un instant sur ce plateau je vous
propose d'abord de regarder ce reportage
un reportage de mélanie poker et quentin
le frère
soudés coupé cloué une dizaine de jeunes
vies sinois créés dans les ateliers de
la ville comme clara et anaïs 11 ans
khlie construisent une horloge j'aime
bien dessiner du coup on m'a dit c'est
bien placé j'ai du bon ok j'y vais pour
dessiner c'est totalement différent mais
ça m'a beaucoup plu saisir que par
exemple des touches du clavier ça peut
se retrouver en personnages en france et
donner une nouvelle vie aux objets quoi
c'est bien elle fondu récup art de l'art
avec des objets de récupération
un atelier pensé par la commune et le
conseil municipal des jeunes avec l'aide
du service jeunesse de claire binet et
plus bas de tous les services municipaux
qui ont joué le jeu on a récupéré à la
déchetterie auprès des services aux
fonds au fond de son garage dans un
grenier dans une cave
tous les objets qui étaient destinés à
être mis donc à la déchetterie nous
sommes déjà la ville de l'agglomération
qui est la meilleure élève en terme de
tri puisque nous avons des taux d'erreur
de trier les plus bas et des taux de
collecte de déchets recyclables comme le
verre ou des les emballages les plus
hauts de l'agglomération elle les
créations seront exposées lors du salon
imagina dès le 7 avril
et pour revenir sur cette semaine
d'ateliers l'artiste et la scénographie
sinon est ce qui a animé cet atelier
c'est à clermont des vernets bonsoir
alors on a vu dans ce reportage donc des
oeuvres créées à partir de matériel
recyclé
c'est à dire que peut créer avec tout
votre avis à peu près avec un petit peu
d'imagination et quelques outils en tous
les cas porter un regard différent sur
ces objets jetés et leur redonner une
seconde vie en détournant souvent leur
sens premier
alors cet atelier s'est déroulée toute
la semaine un stage on peut parler même
d'un stage qui s'est déroulé toute cette
semaine pour pour l'organiser cet
atelier ce qu'on a moins il a fallu
faire du tri justement dans l'aider dans
les déchets oui on travaille dessus
réellement depuis septembre il a fallu
collecter il ya eu beaucoup de matière
qui a été qu'ils ont été rassemblés
nous sommes au ctn au ctm pardon au
centre technique municipal de
voisins-le-bretonneux on a été
chaleureusement accueilli l'atelier
artistique c'est un lieu un peu atypique
pour cet atelier oui c'est vrai alors
pour réfléchir au projet en tant que tel
vous avez complètement raison après on a
besoin de techniques qui a besoin d'un
minimum de doughty les enfants se sont
serviles électroportatif ont appris à se
servir d'une disqueuse d'une ponceuse il
ya une appréhension je crois tout on a
tous une appréhension face à ces outils
et finalement on s'en servant avec
sécurité ça fonctionne très bien et les
gens du du ctm nous ont également appris
à être à bien servir de ça alors je les
ai dit vous êtes artiste et scénographe
visite oise où travailler enfin
travailler que ces objets de
récupération est ce que c'était quelque
chose vous aviez déjà fait ou c'est pour
l'atelier que vous avez menée voilà ces
recherches si je puis dire comment
comment ça s'est passé
je suis directrice artistique d'une
compagnie qui s'appelle la nadal 16
d'abord et depuis 20 ans je crée des
décors souvent à partir d'objets
récupérés
on a souvent c'est la dernière roue du
carrosse le décor le décor d'un
spectacle de théâtre d'une comédie
musicale ou d'une pièce dans les roues
mais ô combien importante au combien
importante donc on fait souvent avec des
objets qu'on récupère très bien et ça
fait travailler l'imaginaire d'avoir des
petits moyens et ça développe le sens
pratique alors variété d'oeuvres sur sur
cette semaine on a pu voir des oeuvres
en rapport avec la ryder cup notamment
enfin oui on a un petit golfeurs qui
commença à prendre forme qui sera
certainement devant l'espace de la tour
de la maison de coville
en étant on est dans le thème on avait
un club de golf on a commencé à
construire un petit bonhomme qui prend
forme qui devrait terminer demain quel
bilan vous tirez sur cette semaine les
enfants ont été assez réceptifs contents
de leur atelier oui ils ont été contents
ils ont vraiment mis la main à la pâte
j'ai aimé aussi réussir à leur
transmettre un message de réflexion
d'abord de se dire quelle est la
différence entre l'art et l'artisanat
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
construire qu'est ce que votre oeuvre
raconte et donc ils ont eu vraiment un
temps pour se poser pour réfléchir avant
de sauter sur les pinceaux les peintures
et les outils dernière chose la suite
maintenant ce travail sera exposé lors
du salon imagine en avril et que
certains voisins bretons nos voisins le
bretonneux du 7 au 14 avril
le salon est ouvert à des enfants à
partir de 3 ans jusqu'à 17 ans donc
écoliers collégiens et lycéens sont les
bienvenus ça leur permettra d'exposer
leurs oeuvres et de voir leur travail
valorisé juste le thème c'est au tour de
la récup très bien merci beaucoup à
claira bina vernet d'avoir été avec nous
rappelle cet artiste et scénographe
originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux y
pour plus d'information justement sur ce
salon imagine en avril je vous invite à
aller sur le site internet de
voisins-le-bretonneux merci d'avoir été
avec nous allez encore un mot de ligne
18 pour refermer ce journal avec une
nouvelle réaction
il m'a rejoint plateau jean michel
fourgous bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
président les républicains de saint
quentin en yvelines alors c'est une
certitude la ligne 18 sera bien réalisé
annonce ce matin du premier ministre
edouard philippe le premier tronçon
quant à lui d'orly à saclay sera
réalisée en retard 2027 ou plus tard
contre 2024 elle arrivait à versailles
elle est donc saint quentin en yvelines
est toujours maintenue à 2030
est-ce que du coup c'est une défaite ou
pas pour le territoire on rappelle que
vous étiez battu récemment pour même
faire avancer ce projet à 2024 pour
l'avoir délais
dès les jeux olympiques qui seront en
2024 thomas j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment les hommes politiques qu'ils
sont élus jusqu'à 2022 peuvent prendre
des engagements d'hier
ce sera pas 2024 ce sera 2030 c'est ce
qui est notre cas pour cinquantaine ses
engagements qui ne pourraient même pas
tenu selon vous mais dans quel pays et
on est ce que dans les grands dix grands
pays font dans le monde
la classe politique travaille comme ça
dans la sincérité avec ses électeurs
avec les élus qui sont ne sont pas
d'ailleurs concertée il ya plus qu il ya
plus que la france où ça se passe comme
ça donc s'il ya un point deuxièmement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de telles
également une sincérité sur les chiffres
quand on vous dit 25 milliards par 92,5
35-38 global la prochaine fois et c'est
vous imaginez les chefs d'entreprises
les investisseurs les dans le privé mais
vous croyez qu'on on joue comme ça avec
les chiffres
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est-ce qui est
pas vrai c'est que c'est la confiance
c'est fondamental entre l'état et les
élus locaux que nous sommes encore qu'à
plus de confiance quand on quand on a ce
nivau de manipulations et des chiffres
et des dattes et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire une majorité qui était jusqu'à 2022
qui prend des engagements qui vous dit
non non je vous promets sera fait en
2030 c'est comme le budget de la défense
on vous dit on ne retrouve pas 300
millions pour les opérations extérieures
de nos militaires et on promet 300
milliards pour 2011 mais c'est l'un des
intéressés ce matin par edouard philippe
le fait qu'il faille mais il faut
maîtriser les budgets 10 à 35 milliard
d'euros la fourchette est grande selon
le selon la cour des comptes pour ce
grand paris express dans sa totalité
c'est un argument qui est pas recevable
pour vous ce surcoût mais est ce que
l'état maîtrise son budget ils viennent
voter un nouveau déficit de 84 milliards
dans la loi de finances 2010 8 il en
continue à augmenter
le budget de fonctionnement de l'état
alors que nous à saint quentin on leur
met on le remet à zéro on maîtrise il
s'essaie la 38ème année où l'état
français est déficitaire alors que nous
on est équilibré j'étais dans nos
collectivités
on a des contraintes bien sûr comptables
différentes mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est c'est ce rôle l'état mais où
il en est là où il va c'est quoi sa
culture dirigeante c'est quoi sa
compétence c'est quoi sa fiabilité
vraiment c'est inquiétant nous demain
j'entends que les maires aujourd'hui 10
bat écouté puisque c'est comme ça moi je
veux ne pas construire les logements qui
étaient ou non je m'étais engagé puisque
si j'ai pas la gare à proximité
c'est en fait son vieux projet dont donc
et puis le développement de paris ckac
et quand même la silicon valley à la
française dont vraiment ce pays a besoin
c'est à dire de 2,2 de préparer des
pôles d'hyper l'hypercroissance qui vont
certainement sauver ce pays parce que
voilà ça s'est il faut il faut déposer
des brevets il faut c'est comme ça que
de même ce pays va serait enrichi réel à
pouvoir garantir les retraites et et et
vous financez bien sûr tous ces grands
projets vous avez n'ont pas touché à ses
grands projets structurants de
l'intelligence française du talent
français de l'excellence française
surtout pas toucher à ça en ce moment
merci jean michel fourgous président de
50 en dix minutes vous aurez d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'en dire plus dans un
instant tout à l'heure vous êtes
l'invité du 7-8 débat amende à bruay
rivera et ses invités reviendront à sur
cette actualité du calendrier de la
ligne 18
voilà ce journal est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi l'édition est à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 très belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]